the Ukraine crisis again focused minds
on the forums third day Germany's
foreign minister made an urgent plea to
all sides to return to the negotiating
table he's been about so I am convinced
it would be irresponsible to miss what
may be the last chance we have to
confuse this conflict is also lesson if
we miss the opportunity expansion and
escalation of the conflict will be a
bigger consequences of a far greater fun
we're also being so persistent because
we have some familiarity with the region
Zen fizzle bahar leash Steinmeier said
Germany would live up to its growing
responsibilities soon afterwards Berlin
announced a for power summit on Ukraine
would be held in Minsk on Wednesday US
Secretary of State John Kerry insisted
the Europeans and the US study united in
the crisis let me assure everybody there
is no division there is no split I keep
hearing people trying to create one we
are united we are working closely
together we all agree that this
challenge will not end through military
force we are united in our diplomacy but
the longer that it takes the more the
off ramps are avoided the more we will
be forced to raise the costs on Russia
and its proxies the US will not be
represented at the Minsk summit but
Chancellor Merkel visits Washington
tomorrow for talks that will also
address the Ukraine crisis along